it is great to welcome to the program
today Jack Barsky who's a retired and
thoroughly reformed ex undercover KGB
agent and also author of the book deep
undercover my secret life entangled
allegiances as a KGB spy in America Jack
it's so great to have you on yeah I'm
delighted to be on and thoroughly
reformed is is very well put so I mean
let's talk for so I've read a lot about
your history but a lot of people may not
be familiar with you you were recruited
by the KGB when living in Europe so tell
us what were you doing at the time where
were you living and how do they approach
you alright so I was born raised and
educated in East Germany which was then
called the German Democratic Republic
it wasn't very democratic but we didn't
really know that it was a vassal state
for the Soviet Union and the Soviets had
pretty much free-range operating in that
country and as well as you know
recruiting some of the best and finest
for their services
I was when when the KGB knocked on my
door literally because of the the first
encounter was in my dorm room I was a
third-year student of chemistry at a
major university what was it that made
them approach you well I had a stellar
record you are you got to understand in
those days and all communist countries
would keep files on every one of their
citizens and it was no doubt that there
was a file about me I I was an A student
I had just received the a national
scholarship which was given to only
about 50-60 students per year in the
entire country you had to you had to be
the complete package you know really
good grades also most would help to be a
party member or at least very active in
the Communist
youth movement and have a few extras
such as you know I played on the
basketball team and you know I I was
popular so I got this on and on top of
it the other thing that was very
inviting to them was the fact that my we
my my parents and I obviously we did not
have any relatives in West Germany that
would immediately disqualify you because
you travel to the west and you meet your
uncle said what are you doing here and
did you know who you were dealing with
right away in other words what's the
pitch that's initially made you the the
pitch was not KGB it was I I thought you
the first encounter I had was with a
german-speaking individual somebody who
was definitely German and the
conversation was a little bit between
the lines you know he initially
introduced himself as he as a
representative of a local optics firm
the world-renowned optics firm who
wanted to talk with me about you know my
my plans after college which was a
blatant and stupid lie because in those
days companies did not recruit you were
assigned after you finished study so so
he he was not really that good so I
figured you know I thought I thought you
might be a Stasi East German security
police and it didn't bother me because I
I had no reason to fear them so I
figured there would be some kind of
recruitment pitch coming and it came
sort of towards the end of our
nonsensical conversation when he when he
changed his tune it says you know what
I'm not really from that company I'm
from the government so can you imagine
to work for the government one of these
days and and I said sure but not as a
chemist so you know he he didn't ask the
question and I didn't answer the
question he didn't ask but we both
understood that I was open to further
talks let's put it this way and then a
week later we we met at a restaurant
he introduced me to somebody who I
didn't expect and that somebody he he
was introduced by the name of Herman
but when Herman opened his his mouth he
spoke with a Russian accent and my
German friend quote-unquote said you you
know we were working with our Soviet
friends bingo I was in the hands of the
KGB and that didn't bother me at all you
know this was this was a promotion right
off the bat you know because the KGB in
those days was clearly the most powerful
intelligence agency in the entire world
what was the training like that started
well initially it was a 18-month slowly
feeling each other out because what they
had in mind for me was undercover work
illegal work and for that you need
certain individuals with a number of
characteristics most most quote unquote
normal people and that's not I'm not
talking down I'm just it's it's a fact
most normal people couldn't do that so
first of all they had to figure out am I
the right material
besides my the the record that I had on
file and secondly I had to figure out
whether I would want to do that so I met
with my handler my liaison at two three
times a month we we got to know each
other really well and I now know that as
soon as he was done with a meeting he
would go back to the office and write a
detailed report and and then he gave me
some little tasks here and there we
talked about life we talked about what
it might be like to operate quote
unquote behind enemy lines it was a very
nice guy who was very friendly and he
got to after maybe 1516 months he came
to the conclusion that he would be worth
actually recruiting not just having a
relationship with and that's when I was
traveling to Berlin where I met a senior
Officer of the KGB at the Soviet
headquarters in East Germany and he was
pretty blunt you know he said well you
know I we need to know whether you you
want to do this or not and I wasn't
expecting that direct and assault so I
was playing for time I said things like
well I'm not really well-trained and I
need to learn this that and that and he
said and he was he was very very
psychologically strong you know when
when this guy opened his mouth you know
there was an authority and so he blurted
out he said in Russian he didn't speak
German and I understood enough Russian
from from high school he said listen we
only work with people who are decisive
so I want an answer by tomorrow noon I
had a very interesting sleepless night
this was not it this was not a slam-dunk
decision because I was on my way to I it
was pretty much a guarantee that I would
wind up a tenured professor at the
University and that was sort of my dream
job now at the time jag is this is an
offer like this does it come with what
we would now consider to be a salary in
the sense that particularly when you're
working in in deep cover often you're
actually working some other job which is
a covering and earning a salary there is
there how are you compensated for your
intelligence work in these roles there
was there was no money was not talked
about and as a matter of fact when I
received now two years initially two
years in in Berlin East Germany I
received two years worth of training and
I was paid the exact same amount I
received as a assistant professor at
that time when I signed up I was already
used assistant professor at the
University so there was no upside to it
eventually when I moved to the west I
there was one year when I didn't have a
job because I need I had to acquire
documentation to
allow me to apply for a job I received
$800 a month plus they paid the rent and
eventually when I had a car up in 50%
all medical expenses and I didn't have
that many you know a young person you
don't go to the doctor that often and
50% of car expenses so when I then had a
job that that paid reasonably well my
first job was interestingly enough I was
a bike messenger in New York City and
this was a contract job so I made enough
money to actually be able to cover my
basic living expenses rent food and all
that and and the salary then went down
to $600 a month but that and that money
was accumulated on account because I
didn't need it
so eventually that after 10 you know 9
years of paying that amount plus an
additional $10,000 as a you know as a as
a bonus one time because I got awarded
the order of the red banner the second
highest decoration of the Soviet Union
anyway
this I don't remember exactly how much
money it was but it was on the order of
$70,000 you go back 30 years that's
about like you know to $250,000 in
today's money on the other side of the
Iron Curtain there was a fortune no
question no question so I want to try to
go through this sort of sequentially so
that the audience understand some of
these different elements so when when
you ultimately came to the United States
you were here as what is colloquially
known as an illegal so there are some
intelligence officers who have a
diplomatic cover they work at an embassy
for example and illegal is someone who
is here you if I recall correctly went
through Canada and had a couple of
different changes of identity and
documents if I if I'm recalling
correctly you were here in a clandestine
sense unknown to anyone in the United
States as who you really were correct we
we actually stole the KGB store
an identity I took on the name and back
story of a young man by the name of Jack
Barsky young man i boy who passed away
at the age of eleven so I the advantages
of being in an illegal I operated as if
you know like all other normal Americans
nobody knew what so I was not restricted
I could do you know I could go places
where the for instance the diplomats
couldn't go they were restricted the
major disadvantage if you're caught you
go to jail and diplomats get you know
you know kicked out of the country yeah
so what were you told as far as that
goes if you get into any kind of
situation is it right to assume that the
Soviet Union would have denied all
knowledge of you know that is absolutely
totally 180 percent on the other side of
the truth good well now we'll figure out
what the truth is okay and you will
understand when I tell you why the why
the truth makes sense the the KGB in
those days when when they had an agent
who was caught and put in jail made
every effort to get them out it
sometimes they had you know some Western
spies in jail and if they didn't they
would set somebody up it would you know
a visiting businessman and put him in
jail on trumped-up charges to get
leverage to get their agents out you
need to understand if if that is not a
part of the future you might be hesitant
to sign up for that gig so so there was
no no sense of denying me but what I was
told initially the this was the plan if
I ever get at court I should stick to my
backstory to my legend up to a point
where it was clear that they were 100
percent sure who I was and and and who I
wasn't and at that point I should have
asked for a diplomatic representative
from East Germany and eventually and
somehow then
whatever could have followed would
follow now getting somebody out of jail
can take a long time I was trained by a
couple that was caught in England
it took the Russians ten years to get
them out hmm yep let's pause there we're
speaking with Jack Barsky who is a
thoroughly reformed ex undercover KGB
agent we will continue the conversation
over on the YouTube channel and go to a
break on our a television and radio show
so Jack one of the things that I think
is an area of curiosity is when you were
told your assignment will be the United
States under the name Jack Barsky what
were you told you would be doing how
long did you expect that you might sort
of be in this sort of only mildly active
set setting and what did you expect
ultimately you might be called upon to
do yeah good good question because I was
not given a lot of background
information I was not for instance told
that the most important thing to them
was my existence rather than all the
other things that they wanted me to do
and I came to that conclusion because I
I met a colleague of mine in in Berlin
year-and-a-half ago he and his wife were
illegals for the KGB in him in the
United States and they had no task other
than just live in the US so here is that
here's the point towards the end of the
Cold War before Gorbachev and Reagan
just uh you know put a stop to that
nonsense there were some moments of very
high tension when it got to a point
where most likely the Russians would
have kicked out American diplomats and
vice versa and there was nobody left on
the other side so to speak and they were
that was so so the sleeper aspect of my
agency was important to them um they
also had some dreams that were
unrealistic
for me to you know befriend people in
high-level positions or influence as a
foreign policy I was supposed to collect
political information primarily no
sabotage fundamentally no industrial
espionage except with at the end they
asked me to to steal whatever I can in
the in the computer world and if I
recall correctly you ended up actually
sending back some software that was not
had not yet reached the Soviet Union at
the time yeah that was on D do not sale
list it was right do not sell lists you
know and so but you know fundamentally
the one thing I can say I I personally
never touched any material that had a
secret written of course and there and
the reason I was saying it was
unrealistic because I didn't have the
standing in society I didn't have the
right background to cozy up to people
who were prominent in in in foreign
policy you know the the the 60 Minutes
interview I made a mistake to mention is
big nybridge in ski who was the security
adviser of national security advisor for
President Carter yeah that was one of
the names that was dropped but you know
it was just as an example they also
dropped thing names like the Hudson
Institute which is still it's a
conservative think-tank and something
you know organizations like like those
and I just I didn't have a good reason
to you know to to introduce myself I
just didn't have the standing in society
I've read that you would send you would
communicate with handlers in what I
recall was a pretty indirect way I think
it was you would write a letter to
someone in was a Denmark maybe and then
they would send the communications on
word yeah it was I had what we call in
the business three convenience addresses
one was in West Berlin
one was in Austria and one was in
Bolivia Venezuela and in a South
American country and it exactly
there was never direct communication
between me and any Soviet agent on the
territory of the United States that was
a absolute no-no there was not allowed
nobody did that not even in an emergency
as a matter of fact the person that I
communicated with you know we we
communicated briefly versus signals
right that person who read my signals or
maybe actually put signals for me to
read most like I would be very surprised
if he knew my real name if he knew my
face I was super super super secret not
to be touched so so that's why my
communication to Moscow was by a male in
secret writing and I received their
orders answers to questions and so forth
by a shortwave radio and what was the
frequency with which you were
communicating what you were up to I the
radio transmissions were scheduled once
a week for ten years there was always a
9:15 in the evening on a Thursday by the
way that was a problem and I complained
I completely I can imagine how that
would be if someone started tracking
what signals are maybe going over the
air if there was a consistent time it
could be problematic no not that because
you know the thing is with a shortwave
transmission you know where it comes
from but you don't know who dials into
it but it established a pattern that
this guy is never available on Thursdays
not funny you know over years and years
and if somebody had paid it let's let's
assume that I accidentally befriends
somebody who really is into
counterintelligence actually or not
what's the matter with Jack I need to
figure this one out right over 10 years
you've never been able to attend an
event with them on Thursday Thursday
available and and you know how do you
how do you
that one and for me I was allowed to
write up to two letters a month and per
letter I was limited to two sheets of
stationery no more you make it thicker
it the people who look at these at the
mail would would more likely want to
take a look what's in there so you know
the communication there wasn't a whole
lot of content really and so I wound up
making a lot of decisions myself yeah
along along those lines
what was your emergency procedure if you
believed that you had been identified
what were you told you were supposed to
do okay so I had on one of my trips back
to Moscow I was given a set of Canadian
documents a driver's license and I don't
know there may have been a social
security card or the equivalent of that
in Canada as soon as I got back to the
US I hid them in a remote park and
that's where they were sitting too and
so if there was an emergency the the
rule was to the more either I figure
it's an emergency so then I just go and
retrieve the documents and and make a
beeline to the us-canadian border at
Niagara Falls in those days you could
walk across there no problem and and and
the vice versa if Moscow was under the
impression that I was in danger there
was a signal that they said and at a
pre-arranged spot and this was on my way
to work I would pass by that signal spot
during the week Monday through Friday
and that signal was a red dot and upon
that red dot no questions asked no
hesitation don't go back to your
apartment just get out of there get your
your emergency documents and make your
way to Ottawa where at that point they
would have exfiltrated me out of Canada
and I want to get I don't want to jump
ahead because at one point that actually
became something that led to you having
to needing to make some decisions but
before we get to that so in the entire
time that you were trained in Europe and
were in the United States at no point
did you ever go to anything even
resembling an official government
building of any kind mean everything was
happening is sort of in public spaces
and at people's homes I mean you never
showed up to work anywhere in your role
as a deep-cover agent no government
building you know eventually I after
this bike messenger
career I went back to school here
I got a undergraduate degree in computer
systems and I got a job at MetLife as a
programmer and so that was it and and
that that provided me with a solid cover
I mean I just was one of the smart guys
who wrote computer code while you were
in the u.s. working in this undercover
format did you feel as though you were
doing something valuable for the Soviet
Union or did you start to sort of
identify more with with your your cover
life because you develop relationships
in that cover life as well yes there's
this is a really good question and it's
a two-fold question first of all I felt
guilty because I felt that I didn't I
hadn't produced enough you know you know
and I always I was always and still am
even at my my age a very ambitious guy I
just want to do good and I had not done
anything your earth shattering so that's
that's the first half of the
and so the second half of the answer
that that's very insightful of you to
ask that question I
it wasn't stated explicitly to me but I
came to the conclusion that the KGB
thought that the shelf-life of an
illegal was around ten to twelve years
because if you are stepping into the
person and into another life completely
completely different in my case it
wasn't just you know from east to west
germany it was to the United States I
you know I was dreaming in English I I
got used to how how you do things in the
United States I even one time I when I
came back from Moscow from a vacation
trip the first thing that I did is turn
turn on the radio and trying to figure
out how the Yankees with doing in the
World Series so I got to a point and I
don't know exactly when but maybe six
seven years into my existence here that
I was thinking you know one day I have
to go back I'm gonna miss this mmm and
this wasn't really hardcore I wasn't
ready to just stay behind for that but
but but I had I had come to like the
work that I did the people that I worked
with and you know a bunch of things that
you couldn't get in the east my my
standard of living here wasn't that
great at the point I was still living in
somewhat substandard apartments and I
had a crummy old car but I liked it and
the other thing I liked it my job in
computer computers was quite demanding
and it got to a point where I really got
annoyed that that I flipped my my day
job was interfered with with the second
job which was the intelligence work
right it seems like at some point you
were not living as Jack Barsky but you
really you became jack Barsky at a
certain I did I did and
I I know this for a fact I had really
managed to develop a different
personality there were some things that
the Germans the German of me never would
have done and the American did and you
know the bottom line is I I here's the
primary example in Germany I I never
ever dated two girls at the same time I
was a serial dater in the u.s. same
thing and I at one point got married to
- I was married to two women the one in
Germany and the one one over here and I
had no compunctions whatsoever well it's
almost like you really were to different
people right I mean there was the German
guy who had his life there and then
there was Jack Barsky here now we didn't
talk about this yet but what did your
German family believe was going on
during this time that you were here in
the u.s. no it depends upon which part
of my German family so I as I said I was
married in Germany my German wife knew
what I was doing where I was going and
she expected about a 10-year period
during which she would see me maybe once
every two years okay
she was vetted by the KGB and was
considered to be trustworthy and you
know they used they like to send couples
but psychologically this young woman
wasn't capable to withstand the pressure
so now she was used as an anchor and
then we had a son so I had an an anchor
in East Germany that gave me a great
incentive to come back my mother my
brother and everybody else friends or
whoever distant relatives all knew one
thing that when I launched to the United
States I started a career in in space
exploration in the Soviet Space Center
in Kazakhstan that was a place that you
could not visit all right it was highly
you know guarded and you couldn't get
anywhere
that place and so I communicated
interestingly enough communicated
throughout there was always a two-year
period during which I was gone and then
I was back in Moscow and Berlin for four
to five weeks and during that time I pre
wrote birthday cards holiday cards as
well as some letters that would
periodically be mailed to my mother
nobody else and she she even believed
this to the very end she actually when
after the wall broke came down she wrote
a letter to Soviet President Gorbachev
asking him to find out no tell her what
happened to me
she passed away without knowing what did
happen Wow
when the emergency signal to you the red
dot finally showed up what did you think
did it occur to you to do what you were
supposed to do did you immediately doubt
whether that's what you wanted to do see
this is this is where I I hope my wife
don't doesn't overhear me because I'm
not supposed to use any bad words but
the first reaction was oh [ __ ] you
didn't doubt you didn't doubt that you
were in danger you didn't think it was a
mistake
actually I sort of doubted it oh you did
because because I had phenomenal the
best training I got was that in and you
know counterintelligence counter
surveillance techniques finding out
whether the FBI was in any way shape or
form trying to to investigate you and I
had no hint whatsoever so but that you
know the dot said nothing it's at just
emergency there was no explanation
obviously so and and here's yes the the
the decisive a piece of information that
made me act the way I did I as I
indicated I was married to a young lady
from
South America who had come here
illegally and by the way I filed for her
citizenship and and she received it in
credit so one illegal made another
illegal legal anyway we had a at the
time an 18 month old daughter and I had
I don't know if you have children but
when I explained this to men who have
particularly little girls they
understand what happened I had fallen in
love with this girl
totally totally 100% and I had tried to
figure out what can I do to support her
so that she can have a good life and
grow up and and not you know wind up in
a bad part of town her mother had a
fourth-grade education so she wouldn't
have been able to provide very well for
her our child and so I had at that point
when I saw that dangerous signal
I had no answer so I just made a quick
decision to ignore it I went back on my
way to work and sat there all day in
front of my terminal not doing much of
anything but nobody noticed so now this
was probably on a Friday so the next
week I listened to my short great wave
transmission and as I'm deciphering this
I read something like you must you must
run as quickly as you can we have reason
to believe the FBI is on your tail oh so
and in France it wasn't it true that the
FBI had had moved into the house next
door to you okay there was there was no
this again I found out after the fact
the fellow that I met my the colleague
of mine was called back at the same time
and they somehow figured out that it was
a false alarm and he was in a position
to go back so he they sent him back
three months
Wow so so whatever they thought was
wrong and I was right in assuming that
that they were wrong but you never know
right it was just an assumption so
anyway now I get this radio transmission
that is still no they didn't know
whether I got when I read the red dot
and they couldn't have known whether I
received a radio transmission at the end
of the transmission
there was a was a directive says set a
signal that you have heard us and I
didn't set the signal now there was
precedent you know one time I was I was
injured in such a way that I couldn't
receive radio signal and and so I had to
explain that to them later the radio
could it could have been broken I could
have been in a hospital so now they next
week oh now and the other thing is at
that point there was another feature of
the emergency procedure they sent the
same radiogram every day day after day
after day and I ignored it so and then
they eventually took a drastic measure
which is was pretty drastic they had one
of their diplomats come up to me on a in
the early morning on a deserted subway
platform and he would come up to me and
uh and whisper in my ears and said you
got to come home or else you're dead Wow
yes and that's a quote you know you can
take this literally or verb or
figuratively I was I was like probably
75% not literal but there's always the
25 percent because I knew that the KGB
had in the past killed defectors so
anyway now at that point I had to make a
decision because now they knew that I
knew that they know so everybody knew
that I knew I
it's supposed to go so the next the next
step for me was to either go or tell him
I'm not going so and I sent him a my
last letter in secret writing indicating
that I'm not going and of course the
question comes how do you resign from
the KGB because I also told them that I
would not go report to I would not
defect I said I'm not going to betray my
country
I'm not gonna betray you guys but I
can't come back because I have hiv/aids
that was a brilliant liar everybody the
fear the fear of that at the time in the
Soviet Union was extraordinary
extraordinary and and we we were talking
about this one time and the Soviets were
convinced that this was a scourge that
was brought upon by the excesses of the
capitalist society and it was the
beginning of the end right and so and
they believed it they didn't have if
they had known that I have an 18 month
old girl there and I was married but
they didn't know this if they had known
that they would have had reason to doubt
the veracity of that claim but they
didn't know this I and so they couldn't
come up with with any kind of reason why
I would make that up because I had all
all the you know I had all that money
back in in Germany I had a wife and a
child I loved that woman
and and they even promised me a house
and you know I would have had a good
life and and would continue to live
outside of the law which was a great
incentive for me because this I don't
like rules a lot well so ultimately the
FBI did catch up with you and of course
people who don't know your story and are
watching would probably say wait a
second how how is how is Jack still here
how is Jack still Jack what it what is
it that transpired because they're on
itíd States typically typically does not
treat those who are here doing what you
were doing particularly well what
transpired and how did you end up being
able to stay allow me to correct
yourself correct you please the it is it
is common practice in the espionage were
that if you find somebody you you
uncover an agent number one you try to
turn them yes now if you can't turn them
you'll throw him in jail or or if they
if they in some way can cooperate they
would very much likely avoid going to
jail and so I did this is what happened
1992 a fellow who used to work in the
KGB archives approached British
intelligence mi6 in Moscow and told him
that you know he had a lot of stuff that
they might be interested in he had
smuggled out bits and pieces of
information out of the archives in small
pieces of on small pieces of paper
handwritten and then transcribed them
and eventually I don't know but it it's
a number of boxes worth of material yet
and in that in that vast amount of
information it was it was a treasure
trove for Western intelligence there was
a little bit about a Jag Barsky who was
an illegal living in the Northeast and
that that information got to the FBI
they ran a scan as to you know they
figured out all the Jack barsky's in
this country and I now have this
information comes straight from the
agent who was the lead agent on my case
who was a good friend of mine now an FBI
agent to be clear yeah sure yes and he
told me that you know very quickly it it
was clear that it had to be me because I
was the only one of those barsky's who
got a social security card at the age of
35 so and that's when they started a
altogether three year investigation very
careful because they had been both the
CIA and the FBI had been burned by
moulds inside Robert Hansen was a mole
in within the FBI and Aldrich Ames was
within the CIA and they were concerned
that I might actually be handling yet
not a mole somewhere they didn't know
whether I was active or I was a sleeper
or I had completely given up all they
knew was that I was a highly trained
agent because I had at that point I had
survived undetected for like 16 years in
the United States right but it took him
a long time and what eventually made
them understand that that I was quote
unquote retired first of all my Joe
Riley the fellow who was the lead agent
he observed me from a distance from a
from a hill across the street and the he
just watched me interact with my
children I had to then at the time and
you know it I let such a normal life and
it was just no hint that there was ever
was doing anything odd number one and
number two that they bugged my house
and one time I had an argument with my
wife and and I wanted to convince her as
to I wanted to give her some information
say look honey I'm really on your side I
am NOT against you I'm not fighting you
guess what I did to be able to stay with
you I used to be a Soviet agent and I
took a huge risk to stay with you and
Chelsea our daughter and they had this
on the house was drugged at that point
yes they had this they had the
confession Wow and so when the
confrontation happens you agreed to
cooperate and then you become Jack
Barsky legal US citizen yes it took a
while first of all the the initial
debriefing by the way I was never really
arrested I was detained the first
conversation was took place in a motel
where the FBI had rented the all the
rooms in of one wing and they had guards
stationed at either end of the up to the
floor and my
my my interrogation debriefing took
place in the in the middle room of that
wing that took two hours and then they
let me go and there's no violent
physical violence during them oh nothing
nothing at all it was all very
professional and very friendly as a
matter of fact Joe Riley see wet so they
introduced themselves and there was a
traffic stop and and he Riley showed his
badge and he said FBI would like to talk
to you please follow us and I had to get
in the car with him
and the first question I asked am i
under arrest
and the answer was no and then then I
you know recovered rather quickly and I
told them I asked him so what took you
so long
hmm and they didn't laugh but I think
internally they chuckled a little bit
that was pretty brazen with me too you
know as a kind of question but I just
wanted to break the ice anyway at that
point and Riley turned around from from
the front and said this jack this may
not be the worst day of your life so I
there was a glimmer of hope and so and
so at this point you know I had I had
lost not only my belief in communism I
had also lost my allegiance to whatever
state existed because it didn't exist
anymore East Germany was gone the Soviet
Union had fallen apart it was in the
late that 1990s so there was nothing
there wasn't so nothing I should
withhold from the US authorities so I I
told him everything I knew and it took
six six full weeks to finish the
debriefing and at the end I also had to
pass a lie-detector test and when that
all happened and the I passed the test I
was told they would work on getting me a
green card and eventually I I could
obtain citizenship that decision I I was
told was made by the director of the FBI
there have been since that point have
you had any are you aware of any
attempts to reach you from what what is
now the former KGB at the time was the
KGB did have they contacted you in any
way no I was dead as far as they knew
yeah I was dead and and the first time
there was an indication that I wasn't I
mean if if somebody they didn't have a
good reason to search for me since I was
dead right right so if they had they
could have found me somehow but they
didn't now I entered the public realm
four years ago my first interview was
with a German news magazine and at that
point somebody could have you know read
this and found out hey this guy is still
alive but nothing happened you know
there was way too much time had passed
since my resignation and they knew that
wouldn't wouldn't make much sense to to
contact me so now you live here you live
under the name that was initially sort
of a character in a sense that you were
playing an assumed identity of size do
you I mean do you regret it do you feel
like it worked out the right way yeah
see in my mind I'm playing the alternate
scenario and and I witnessed what the
outcome might have been so I was a party
member I was a rising star at the time
the KGB recruited me I had two offers to
either take a position full-time
position in the local party or become
the deputy head of the Communist Youth
movement at the University which would
have eventually after two years and
that's the way that succession work
would have made me in charge of the the
10,000 students hmm which this is you
know a springboard to a career in
government ah now I'm thinking in a
and you know I have God gave me half way
decent brain and I I would have been a
standout in most places so I would have
gone up the ladder and here's a point
where I probably would have figured out
like some of my colleagues my
contemporaries that something is not
right in that place I would have seen
some things that would have made me
think oh my god
and so I have a my best friend German
friend he was a really smart guy he he
joined the East German security force as
a chemist and so he eventually wound up
heading the forgery department
interestingly enough he most likely they
they produced passports that I may have
used to travel because the KGB bought
them from the Stasi but anyway he sensed
that something wasn't right like two
three years before you know the wall
came down but you know what do you do
you have a career you have a family you
have a child what do you do and so when
when the wall came down in East Germany
crumbled he that didn't you know it was
like the realization that you worked
your entire life were you dedicated to
to a wrong cause it's very painful and
it took him a long time to overcome this
and I think I may have had the very
similar fate if I had stayed back there
so the detour that I made to become an
American I ultimately I appreciate it
what I don't what I very much regret is
the the damage that I did to some people
such as my mother and my German wife I
can't undo this but you know it wasn't
done on purpose or it was done because I
thought I was serving a higher cause bad
it's an incredible story we've been
speaking with
Jack Barsky who as you can hear is a
thoroughly reformed ex undercover KGB
agent check out his book deep undercover
my secret life entangled allegiances as
a KGB spy in America Jack I so
appreciate you spending some time with
us today yeah you're most welcome